crunch time for the prime minister who
must decide this week whether plan b
measures need to change
whichever path he chooses it's clear
boris johnson won't please everyone
would you like to see further
restrictions come in now yes absolutely
i think the numbers are way too high
we're starting to confuse testing with
uh severity of a disease
and i wish they'd stopped testing people
because if we just got on with life we'd
soon be back to normal but it's the
tests which are providing one of the key
indicators hitting over a hundred
thousand positive results for three days
in a row leading up to christmas
figures weren't released over the
holiday weekend but are expected to
reach new highs when they're outlined
later today
scientists warned the time for action is
now
we're in a little bit of a black hole at
the moment because we don't know what's
happened over the last two days an
argument for restrictions would be to be
able to flatten this curve of cases a
little bit to enable
the hospitals and the nhs and the
services
to be maintained
soaring cases enough to scare the
scottish government into toughening up
restrictions there
no white christmas this year
this and other theater shows now closed
for weeks
in northern ireland there are further
restrictions on hospitality from today
as well as renewed social distancing
rules
testing times in wales too
a return to social distancing and
one-way systems among new measures there
and nightclubs are closed
in england this was the scene last night
open and desperate to stay so
the coveted passport situation which we
saw in wales scotland and northern
ireland initially being
administered
that was led to be it was supposed to be
a mitigation that would allow nightclubs
to remain open that clearly hasn't
happened
today boris johnson is expected to
examine the latest hospital data before
making a decision encouraging signs
there and england could be saved from
toughened new rules
but if the figures suggest concern for
the nhs the prime minister may find
himself caught between scientific advice
and back bench reluctance to support new
measures sardia chaudhary sky news